I'm here to settle the beef guys as you
know I've been a good boy lately no no
fights just vegetarian no beef until
recently I got in a little bit of a
Twitter fight with the world's richest
Gambler a man who supposedly made 360
million dollars gambling and has nothing
better to do than go back and forth with
me so I'm here to settle it today once
and for all because I admit I started
off a little heated I called him a dirt
bag for making you know basically his
fortune off the backs of his viewers
because he promoted to them gambling and
he didn't like that he he came back at
me with both gloves off he said I
thought he meaning I was a credible
Source until I read this trash referring
to something I had just written
um and to that I I just have to stop it
right there and say you used to think I
was credible now unfortunately for him
this is the biggest cope I hear all the
time I used to think coffee Zilla was
credible but then he talked about me
now actually one recent hit video came
out by a guy called coffee Zillow
actually kind of respected and thought
Had a Brain but whatever I loved
coffeezilla
and then he talked about my thing we
hear it all the time okay let's continue
though let's continue let's not hold it
against him he thinks I glamorized
gambling now I know where he gets his
news from he also says this guy clearly
doesn't watch nor has he ever watched me
everything he's saying is the opposite
of who I am what I do now what is this
in reference to okay well it's a recent
Revelation that train wrecks made if you
don't know he's one of the biggest uh
gambling streamers before twitch banned
gambling recently and just two days ago
there policy change went into effect
meaning stake's number one employee
train wrecks he just got released from
contract right he's no longer employed
by them because he can't really promote
them uh and because of that he decided
that I guess he's gonna come clean and
just say you know what he made I'll
release what I got paid since the
beginning of my contract I've been paid
360 million dollars for 16 months of
gambling
there you go wow every time I've heard
that and I've played that clip multiple
times it's still always a shocking
amount of money 360 million in 16 months
promotingstate.com now we'll talk in a
second about whether this number's real
it's been a lot of talk a lot of people
don't think it's possible that this
number's real even for the numbers we've
heard on stake.com which people get paid
Millions a month
um to promote gambling on there it's
excessive even for that but we'll talk
about that in a second the point is I
responded to that by saying because he
posted this clip or somebody posted this
clip of him saying this I said what a
crazy thing to brag about getting paid
360 million to gamble train arcs only
got paid that because he converted
viewers into losers for the casino what
a dirt bag I then say it isn't
complicated gambling is addictive it has
the highest rate of any addiction and
that people like train glamorize
degenerate gambling and this is where I
lost my spotless reputation with train
okay because according to him he doesn't
claim rice gambling he calls himself and
I quote The anti-gambling Gambler
I'm not kidding
and if you can tell me what that is if
you can tell me how you can be an
anti-gambling Gambler professionally
gambling for millions of dollars
16 hours a day you let me know okay but
I do want to take him seriously for a
second that's actually why I'm making
this video is it true that you can uh
not glamorize gambling while making
hundreds of millions of dollars is that
true I wanted to kind of think about
that for a second because my initial
thought was you know they're probably
better and worse ways to do it but
you're always going to be the least
dirty of the dirt bags if that makes
sense it's never really a you're not
gonna Never Gonna feel good about it but
I wanted to go over you know the full
case I wanted to go over why train
wrecks TV calls himself The
anti-gambling Gambler because in some
ways it is true that unlike other
streamers who used fake money he claimed
he used real money unlike other
streamers who highlighted only their
wins train wrecks would highlight his
losses I think it's train wreck do not
gamble idiots you understand if you
watch the entire context of all my
gambling over 15 months you'll see it as
99.8 percent [ __ ] losing you might
say that okay that's positive you know I
I can acknowledge that what Steve will
do it was doing on rubette was probably
worse than what train was doing on state
because Steve will do it was just kind
of Faking everything however
do you know who actually made more money
for the casinos at the end of the day
despite all the claims of being like
this like woke anti-gambling Gambler
train
by a long shot he is one of the top
gambling streamers getting paid the most
for his gambling content and we all know
why that is these business deals don't
happen from nowhere they don't just make
up the numbers oh you get 50 million you
get five million you get one million
they're based on getting people in the
door you get paid because you get people
to play you can Shuffle the numbers
around whatever but you'll never get
your deal get canceled if you're not
pulling in the numbers that's just the
bottom line okay so the very fact that
he says that I made 360 million dollars
if that's true he at least pulled in 360
million dollars for the casino that's
basically that admission and that's why
I'm saying wow what what a scumbag right
so this is where I think as a streamer
no matter how based you are you know
like trains you know he puts in the top
right hand corner of his stream like
don't gamble you'll lose and then the
other 95 of the like screen is him
gambling
um I think no matter how much you do
that gambling 16 hours a day you can't
help but glamorize it why well because
the opposite of glamorizing something is
being realistic right that's obvious and
showing the reality of gambling would be
train would gamble for about 10 seconds
spending a thousand dollars a spin and
run out of money instead he gets to
gamble 16 hours a day or eight hours a
day whatever he does for an entire 16
months and he makes money makes millions
of dollars right that is a glamorous
picture of gambling no matter how much
you you preach about oh guys I'm just
doing it and making millions I don't
want you to do it oh please don't don't
care don't gamble so no matter how much
he talks about his losses it can only be
so real when he shows up the next day
and Gamble balls again I also want to
quickly address the other side of this
argument of personal accountability
shouldn't people who gamble because they
watch train wreck streams uh be
accountable themselves and yeah to some
extent I think you should be on the
other hand I only think you should take
accountability when these streamers take
accountability because there's a whole
other side to this as much as people
like train want to say that uh the
problem is no one wants to take
responsibility for their own actions he
he's the one who doesn't take
responsibility for his own actions he
wants to be seen as some woke
anti-gambling gambler but also get to
reap the rewards of promoting gambling
and getting tons of people to gamble
he's unwilling to just own the fact that
he made a casino probably over 360
million dollars like if people can be
accountable for losing their life
savings why can't you be accountable for
what you did here's the deal they have
no problem taking accountability when it
comes to taking their cut of the check
right like when State goes to him and
goes hey here's your 20 million for the
month for all these people you signed up
train wrecks doesn't go whoa whoa whoa
that wasn't me that was their personal
accountability nah he's like yeah I did
a I promoted that I got these guys in
the door you pay me my money and fair
enough he did get him in the door but as
soon as it's as soon as he gets the
slightest amount of Social pushback and
people are like wow that's actually
pretty scummy that you do that for money
he's like oh my gosh I can't believe
you're accusing me of glamorizing
gambling it's like yeah you're paid to
do that you did a great job of it why
why can't he take personal
accountability for that that's sort of
my whole problem with this is like
people want it only on one side they
want the guy who gambled to take
personal accountability but the guy who
got him in the door he no problem over
here no we have to ignore this guy right
that's sort of my problem with this
whole thing I think train tries to you
know um dismiss this fact by saying that
he really doesn't make steak.com that
much money this guy he calls into
question the whole claim of 360 million
he says 22.5 million per month I call
Cap ain't no way he generates that much
value per month train responds I don't
they lose money on me it's how I can
gamble as a anti-gambling gambler now I
don't know if he's like willfully
delusional here or he's just lying it's
straightforward business guys if you
believe this it's ridiculous no business
is going to offer you a deal if they are
going to get a add Roi they're either
expecting long-term profits or
short-term profits there's no other way
they're going to pay you okay this is
ridiculous he's trying to pretend like
he's the he's like got in The Matrix
underneath and like is secretly
subvertingstake.com and running them at
a negative no shot he's making the
millions of dollars a month and he's
getting paid for that because that's how
this works if he wasn't bringing in more
money than he was making they would have
cut the deal off yesterday now I do want
to say though this isn't to say that
this 360 million dollar number is
accurate and uh I agree that this seems
outrageous although it could be real a
real number without being accurate uh
this could be the amount like he got
after you factor in the amount he lost
back to stake like they could have
factored in that he was going to gamble
roughly 200 300 million of it over the
lifetime of that contract so we really
don't know how much that breaks down how
much he was bringing home but I think
it's fair to say that he made a fortune
off the back of his viewers who gambled
away a fortune while watching him but
anyways I just wanted to show the
hypocrisy of this whole like woke
anti-gambling Gambler thing where you
can have it both ways of like oh I'm
making millions of dollars getting
people to gamble but also I'm like the
good guy though I'm like the good one
I'm the good good guy getting him in the
door either way you're getting people
like hooked right that's the whole
purpose of this whole thing so uh yeah I
don't know personal accountability runs
both ways if if you can say that
someone's responsible for for walking in
the door I can say you're a scumbag for
showing up the door anyways yeah that's
it that's the beef bye